oh hey welcome back quit get inside it's
dangerous out there you're just in time
to see the most terrifying thing from
Attack on Titan this brutal story about
massive walls protecting the last of
humanity was a lie the walls were never
a defense they a weapon buried within
the Harden Stone surface are colossal
Titans an entire Army of colossal Titans
they rest here dormant waiting to be
awakened with a single mission to
destroy the world in this video you're
getting a glimpse of the Apocalypse what
if the rumbling was
[Music]
real again I'll try my best to avoid
story spoilers like the last time I made
a video about Attack on Titan but with
the conclusion of the anime I just have
to talk about the
rumbling I won't mention any details so
don't worry if you're not caught up I
mean not all of us have made it to
season 4 part 3 episode 2 chapter 5 but
regardless I think it's time for us to
see some Fishbones that's the nickname
I've given to the largest and most
bizarre Titan in the entire series
consisting almost entirely of exposed
bones this giant rib cage Titan measures
over a kilometer in length with the
spines on its back reaching 650 M tall
simply put this Titan Towers over most
modern city skyscrapers though would
still be shorter than the tallest
building in the world although I have no
idea how the heck this thing is supposed
to even move I mean does it just float
around like a blimp does it crawl Along
on its bones like the legs of a
centipede or what if it just stood up on
the wait are those legs look at those
legs just when I thought this Titan
couldn't get more bizarre somehow this
takes it there so yeah perhaps it's a
good call not having it stand up like
this the main thing to know about this
monstrosity is that it controls the army
of Titans that are waiting within the
walls according to Legend the walls were
formed from countless colossal Titans
standing shoulder toosh shoulder using a
special hardening ability to grow the
walls around them they encased
themselves inside however once awoken
the walls would crumble and reveal a
literal clone army of the single most
dangerous Titan it's a force capable of
destroying the entire world without
having to do more than just walk see
unlike the threat of traditional weapons
like guns or bombs this weapon is an
Unstoppable tidal wave that will
hydraulic press the entire world until
it's flat so how many wall Titans make
up this Force the show never gives us a
legit answer but fortunately they did
leave enough breadcrumbs for us to
figure out because yeah I did the math
in order to calculate the scale of
rumbling we need two things the size of
the walls and the Titans inside now I
always assume that the wall Titans were
the same size as the Colossal Titan but
there's a big problem with that
assumption the Colossal Titan is taller
than the
wall I mean this guy looming above the
wall is one of the most iconic images
from the story how is he supposed to fit
inside that's what she said one possible
answer is that the wall Titans are just
shorter but there's actually some
evidence from season 1 suggesting
they're not there's a story of a minor
who tried to Tunnel beneath the wall but
hit Bedrock about 10 m down implying
that maybe he just hit the hardened feet
Seas of the wall Titans themselves so
all right then I guess that means the
wall Titans are 60 M tall 20 M wide and
buried at least 10 m down this actually
makes a lot of sense because any wall is
going to need a solid foundation so it
doesn't just fall
over but how big are these walls they
reside on the island of paradee but if
you flip the map it looks just like
Madagascar with the east coast of Africa
resembling Marley this suggests that the
world of Attack on Titan is simply a
mere version of Earth but the numbers
tell a different story episode one
revealed the radius of the three walls
surrounding humanity meaning the total
area within the walls is
723000 square
km is that a lot not only is that bigger
than Madagascar but it's bigger than
Texas Texas this little devil island is
so much bigger than any of us realize if
we cut up up the walls and string them
together into a line they'd be about
7,000 km long that's the distance from
Las Vegas to New York City and back that
is immense but let's not forget that the
Great Wall of China is three times
longer than that it's also real so you
know ain't no Titans waiting in
there
right okay it's time to answer the big
question how many Titans are in the
walls
350,000 this number alone is colossal
and would make it the 16th largest army
in the world if they were normal sized
but they're not they're colossal Titans
just one is already the most dangerous
creature in the entire world the danger
is mainly just from their feet because
all they need to do is step on you with
their tremendous weight I calculated
that the weight of each of these Titans
is 6 million kg that's the same weight
as 52 blue whales but stuffed inside a
creature that walks on two legs when
walking we apply anywhere from like 1
and 1/2 to three times our own body
weight until to the force of each step
oh my
God oh my and with the footprint the
size of a studio apartment that means a
lot of demolition look at the size of
this even the concrete of the road
doesn't stand a chance despite having a
lot of strength the ground underneath
the road gives way causing the brittle
concrete to flex and break apart pH that
was a close one but fortunately he
didn't step on
me oh no
now obviously your feet don't cover all
the ground when walking but with enough
people around every square inch sees the
bottom of someone's foot
350,000 pairs of feet is a lot but in
order to leave no ground un stomped the
marching Titans would need to be
multiple rows deep they need to walk in
a line so that the ground can get
completely flattened by all of the
footsteps so how many would it take
after scaling down a Titan to my height
and laser cutting its footprint into a
stamp
I have tighten feet I set out to walk
along the stretch of dirt until it was
fully stomped
down okay now I'm going to go do it
again and to my surprise it only took
seven passes to completely stomp it all
which means that the marching formation
only needs a column of seven Titans to
squash the whole world and the rumbling
itself would be at least like 1,000 km
wide it's a fraking megameter line of
pure destruction they would have to comb
across the world going back and forth
like a lawnmower perhaps there' even be
some overlap so they don't end up with
little gaps in the annihilation you know
but the story takes place in an early
industrial era where there aren't large
scale cities or buildings 60 M Titans
are literally the biggest things around
but that's not the case in a modern city
the main point I made about the Colossal
Titan in my first video is that it's
just not as big as you might expect
because compared to a modern city it's
really not you could hide dozens of
colossal Titans inside New York City
because most of the buildings in
Manhattan are significantly taller than
them in the modern world 60 M just isn't
all that big anymore and wait wait hold
up is that what I think it is okay I
guess not apparently it's just a train
station but come on it's even on a
system called The Path eh eh no remember
the Godzilla movie that came out in '98
starring Ferris berer that's a lot of
fish this Silla stands only slightly
taller than the Colossal Titan at 70 M
tall but it wrecked New York City most
buildings can withstand things like
earthquakes but bump a giant shoulder
into it and there's no way that
building's not getting condemned and
that's not even mentioning how much
damage the military ended up doing to
the
city work the Titans certainly make much
easier targets than a dodging lizard but
there's still one more trick up the
Titans muscly sleeves they can emit
super critical steam we're talking about
steam that is so hot it can ignite cloth
on fire like 6 or 700° hot so not only
are these Titans stomping everything to
a pulp but they're also burning it all
as well steam might not be able to get
hot enough to melt steel
beams but it doesn't have to the
tremendous amount of heat generated by
these Titans would easily be enough to
destroy a city I mean the windows would
melt even the concrete of the buildings
would be damaged from the heat I mean
just look at how a simple pallet fire in
Los Angeles destroyed a highway traffic
has been awful which begs the question
if the rumbling were to happen in the
real world today could we resist could
we fight back and win to kill a Titan
you have to destroy the nape of its neck
and over the course of the show the
characters innovate new ways to do this
from swords and omnidirectional movement
gear to these things called Thunder
Spears fast forward to our reality and
we have guided missiles fighter jets and
even freaking nuclear bombs so yeah I
think we could win in fact I dare say
that the rumbling is less dangerous to
us than we are to ourselves it's the
consolidation of power that's the real
danger and I think that's why I still
find the concept of the rumbling so
haunting one of the themes of Attack on
Titan is inevitability the idea that we
as humans cannot change our nature and
are therefore powerless to change our
future but if that's true then where do
we go from here how do we keep moving
forward if what we're moving toward is
this is it possible to change a story
that's already been written is it
pointless to even
try no I don't believe in a
deterministic universe
the future is ours to
write thank you so much for watching
this was a huge labor of love and I hope
you like it as much as I'm proud of it
if you want to keep watching some more
Attack on Titan content guess what we
have a whole other scale of Attack on
Titan video right here for your
enjoyment pleasure that's a phrase this
was a really fun year of making videos
and I'm looking forward to making some
more next year so see
you